[Music]
all right guys last night such a special
episode around as long when your
favorite part these last couple of weeks
watching this relationships kind of
unfold and grow I think I'm a fans
reaction very so happy and I yeah I love
right the Amundsen fans have been
amazing and I think we've slowly been
giving David water ya know out the past
year so to see their reactions in such a
positive way is awesome someday yeah and
also I think it was cool for us would be
like finally like yeah MSN is together
it was kind of tying everything together
and all the relationships are kind of
you know working out and there's some
bumps but it was really special for
Allison so it's really like admit for
her feeling it was a cool arc for me and
I really really loved playing out and so
it yeah I love that we still don't know
who the baby's dad is
so how is the identity reveal going to
affect Emison I mean the audience I
think the girls have been through so
much with each other you know separately
that I don't really think anything can
take them down so whatever the result is
whatever the dad is I mean I hope
they're that haven't heard about them I
think we baby names are we going to get
a baby name by series and and what about
an engagement you know what this is
awesome because we shot this so long I
truly can't remember so it's not even
like I really I honestly can't even
remember
so really terrible I remember one and
that was that was it we need we need to
look back of course I'm not going to say
yet you kidding
oh good secret ad told Aria last night
that things are going to get even
Messier for the girls can you guys
elaborate on that I mean we still have
what is it two more episodes us yeah a
lot of happen I mean that threat was was
fed with some weight behind it what do
you guys think of all the twin theories
that are out there I think everybody can
have a theory but I mean we haven't
really stayed true to anything so always
have your own your own theories I love
hearing them but
you'll have to wait and see I think
everyone's always wanted it went the
twin theory because of the book but you
know Marlene always districts inversely
so I think it I think it turned out
really well if the fans are going to
love it regardless yes we talked to
Marlene earlier this week and she teased
the possibility of a spinoff would you
guys be interested in an Emerson
spin-off I mean you never know what
could happen in Rosewood you know that's
always what I say the possibilities are
endless yeah
you